what is that over there
they're often they call the bread we're
eating right now
this is like a big what is it I don't
know it's like a big one it's like a big
Italian food Mart where they make all
this stuff fresh the pasta to thread the
meat well I don't make the meat fresh
but they cut it fresh
katia machine
a lot of grief about those sneakers
today not think he knew it there any
black shoe balls
actually I played see
yeah
$1 for that
outrageous
let's check it out the macro lens look
see look at that that's amazing
innovating
what's going on this week said whatever
we done
it's birthday hey how old is it what do
you know
zowie eight that's what we that's what
we just ate see I don't approve as you
know because you follow my videos rule
number two Instagram for me is don't
take pictures of food and yet every
single person in my family did that
today how old are you turning this
weekend 20900 flavor what flavor
clever do you wants it I don't know back
Roland's sake calm
Vennela salted caramel
hey I'm Stephen fine I'm here to talk
about the characteristics of hydrogen
bonds